[Music]  let's hop on one of those ships and sail  away  that sounds nice  hey  you got company  why don't you think about where we would  go  far  far  away from here  come on  show me a ticket one more charm man  [Music]  i was just thinking about my mother  what was she like  beautiful  shattered  you are not here  you issue  this angel  finest girl west of the rockies i have  to meet him  what's your pleasure mister  the truth is i  didn't come here for  that you have been broken your innocence  holding they're gonna marry me  take me away from here give me the life  i deserve  [Music]  do not give way to such feelings as  these  they will ruin your happiness  [Music]  you can't choose to laugh you won't  [Music]  she just does not love you she is using  you you have no idea  who she is  you have to stop thinking that i'm gonna  be something that i'm not  that way is home  or choice  oh i will rescue  you  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you